though the film might involve the
destruction of all humanity don't look
up seems like it was a whole lot of fun
for the cast to shoot the netflix dark
comedy film brought together an
incredible cast of talented actors like
leonardo dicaprio jennifer lawrence
meryl streep jonah hill tyler perry kate
blanchette ron perlman under the
leadership of comedic director adam
mckay when you imagine all those
personalities on set you know they
probably got up to some friendly
shenanigans but out of everyone who
appears and don't look up the one person
who seemed to surprise the cast the most
with his off-screen behavior was timothy
chalamet the young stars don't look up
role in itself is already somewhat
surprising to say the least you might be
used to seeing him as the heroic paula
tradies in dune or a cool comparatively
serious character in historic dramas
like the king and little women but in
don't look up he appears as yule a
seemingly detached shoplifting slacker
who turns out to be a deep thinker with
an unexpected affinity for religion of
course it should be noted that despite
his general propensity toward more
serious roles there's far more to
chalamet than oscar bait dramas as part
of a four-year consideration cast
interview jennifer lawrence described
how chalamet showed a completely
different side to him than what people
would expect from someone who's known
for more dramatic roles according to
lawrence the young actor was constantly
cracking people up on set while filming
scenes with them she explained
timothy gave us all so much comedic
relief and
because he was improving and was just
killing leo
lawrence's character kate and don't look
up meets chalamet's yule inside a
supermarket where she works and later
forms a bond with him the two spend the
majority of chalamet's screen time
together with dicaprio eventually
joining them in the interview lawrence
describes a moment during filming when
she saw dicaprio struggle to keep his
composure
and so i had to wait until they called
cut but i just saw leo's face like he
wasn't on camera but his face was just
bright red and he like couldn't breathe
he was holding in a laugh
she continued
and i had to wait until cut to be like
what do you say
what do you say
he would say the most random stuff
the fact that chalamet was able to get
one over dicaprio like that is a pretty
impressive achievement considering that
dicaprio himself is a known onset
jokester the people who only know
timothy chalamet from his dramatic roles
might be surprised by the fact that he's
hilarious enough for jennifer lawrence
to go out of her way to specifically
mention it however those super fans who
have followed chalamet's career from the
beginning are no doubt aware that the
kind of deadpan comedy he unleashed upon
his co-stars is well within the actor's
skill set after all he plays the
revolutionary youth zephyrelli in wes
anderson's the french dispatch and you
don't get cast in a wes anderson movie
without having a penchant for dry humor
it's also highly unlikely that anyone
would get cast as willy wonka without
plenty of kooky comedic sensibility at
their disposal considering that chalamet
will be the latest actor to make his
mark by playing the eccentric candy
maker in the upcoming wonka his comedic
bonafides can't be ignored and it seems
that his comedic sensibilities aren't
limited to just when the cameras are
rolling per gq chelami's friend
filmmaker and actor greta gerwig has
confirmed that his offbeat sense of
humor extends beyond the professional
environment too she describes talking
with chalamet we can get on the phone
and talk for an hour or more without
even realizing it just skipping from
subject to subject making jokes me
feeling old and happy and him being
funny and anxious and delightfully all
over the place check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one